azul el ex en gusta conocerte como lo
dicen seguir y como lo dejamos es como
esa cosa a la que le pueda decir alexa
pone una canción jubilee 10 contra 1
cita a ciegas con 10 chicos cómo te
sientes siendo honesta me siento
nerviosa
le pedimos al ex a que saliera
rápidamente con 10 posibles parejas y
seleccionar a la persona más compatible
sin poder verlo sientes que conocerás
bien a la persona aunque no puedas verla
si siento que lo haré soy bastante buena
para captar las inflexiones de las voces
y todo eso puedo decir si alguien está
haciendo esto conmigo no por su voz así
que creo que lo haré muy bien
[Música]
todos los que no estén sentados pongan
algo de música hagan lo suyo
[Música]
primera ronda las presentaciones
cuál es tu nombre soy miguel cuál es el
tuyo me llamo alexa es un placer el
placer es mío tu nombre es muy lindo
gracias no tienes tengo 18 cuántos años
tienes tengo 23 valente tienes alguna
meta a futuro si una de mis metas ahora
es tener dinero para comprarla mi mamá
su propia casa eso me encantaría me
llamo alexa vaya como mi mamá en serio
sí estoy estudiando para ser bióloga
marina o psicóloga estudio en viola una
universidad cristiana genial eres
cristian se ve mucho solo un poco mucho
estás trabajando estás estudiando algo
sin trabajo en conseguir un trabajo
háblame de ti qué haces soy estudiante a
tiempo completo como me encantan todas
las artes como la pintura la fotografía
cosas así
en realidad me gustan mucho los aviones
también la fotografía a veces tomó
algunas
con mi cámara así que supongo que
tenemos algo en común que me cuentas en
nombre styler voy a hacerte una pregunta
rápida que es muy importante si fuéramos
al mundo del yogur le pondrías chocolate
fruta tu yogurt es algo que necesito
saber le pondría a ambos y en algo
salvaje me doy cuenta esto es solo
locura cómo estás estoy bien me puedo
dar cuenta por tu tono de voz suena con
mucha muy extrovertida primera ronda la
eliminación
alexa debe eliminar a dos personas de la
cita en realidad
aunque tendré que eliminar a jd porque
no sentí que hubiera una conexión lo
mismo con el que vino después de calde
porque tampoco sentí una conexión
[Música]
lo siento
segunda ronda la cita ideal
no quiero sonar demasiado cliché visita
ideal sería dar largos paseos por la
playa pero también siempre quise subir a
una noria con una chica guapa
probablemente la mía sería conducir por
ahí y quizás terminar en la playa
pretender que sé de constelaciones y
demás se diría de una vez que soy muy
malo para planificar citas
si conoces esos comedores tipo retro y
los que tienen colores y luces de época
creo que serían buenos de acuerdo muy
bien presta atención porque pensé mucho
en steam estoy trabajando para obtener
mi licencia de piloto entonces estoy
pensando que tú y yo podemos subirnos a
un avión privado en el aeropuerto verdad
volamos por la costa de california hay
pequeñas islas podríamos volar a una de
ellas y como te gusta la fotografía
atraes tu cámara y tomas algunas fotos
hay que compartir memes entre nosotros
porque me bancó de memes es una locura
así que si no tienes buenos gustos en
memes no va a funcionar para nada confía
en mí tengo una carpeta entera tal vez
deba comprar un animus la risa
creo que la risa es muy muy buena me
gusta hacer imitaciones y cosas por el
estilo como pantera mil veces
segunda ronda
la eliminación voy a tener que eliminar
vamos a ver mikel inicialmente sentí una
especie de conexión pero después se fue
perdiendo poco a poco y también eliminó
a quien sea la tercera persona pero es
porque dijo que era malo para planificar
a mí me gustan las personas que son
buenas planificando y organizando me
encanta ser creativa y todo ese tipo de
cosas así que
[Música]
tercera ronda el factor decisivo creo
que personalmente si alguien no es
elocuente si estás en una cita o lo que
sea explicar quién eres realmente y cómo
te sientes va muy lejos en una relación
yo diría ya que sé cristiano que beber o
fumar un poco está bien pero si es en
exceso ya eso es algo complicado sobre
el tema de fumar y beber a mí no me
gustaría salir con una persona fiestera
eso de salir cada fin de semana no es mi
estilo que hay de nuevo siento que
necesito a alguien que pueda hacer tu
erc sabes pues eso es lo que quiero
incluso si no puedes hacerlo también
quiero que lo intentes quiero alguien
divertida quiero que continuemos donde
lo dejamos la última vez me o cuál
dirías que es tu gran talento am supongo
que puedo cantar pero no tengo mucha
confianza en ello como - no canto
horrible es sólo que no lo he hecho en
público de acuerdo tal vez te puede
ayudar de alguna forma
tercera ronda la eliminación a leche
debe eliminar a dos personas del sitio
rápido el primero va a tener que ser
tyler el habló sobre hacer tu aire' y
todo eso yo nunca lo he intentado no sé
si puede hacerlo pero no parecía que
fuera muy serio con la relación luego
voy a tener que eliminar a mccalebb no
hay ninguna razón en particular es solo
que ya no siento una conexión con él
[Música]
cuarta ronda me gustaría poder decir que
puedo tener una casa pero espero tener
una familia ya formada a los 30 cuántos
hijos quieres quisiera tener un niño y
una niña para ser honesto y luego unos 3
o 4 perros si quiero que el niño sea
mayor que la niña me gustaría al revés y
la niña puede intimidar al niño 10.000
para mí es algo muy importante e intento
convertirme en piloto y me enlisté en la
marina para cumplir esa meta todavía
estoy trabajando en ello pero si
quisiera que mi pareja tuviera la misma
mentalidad que yo no puedes estar en una
relación donde una persona esté motivada
y la otra no cierto lidió con mucho
entonces soy músico y actor pero también
estudió ciencias políticas y quiero ser
presidente de los eeuu así que
obviamente me gustaría estar con alguien
que sea comprometida pero también que
pueda ser un apoyo y de quien pueda
aprender mucho y eso realmente significa
mucho para mí que hay de ti me estoy
inclinando a estudiar psicología para
poder ayudar a los adolescentes señora
externos mentales creo que hay una
conexión genuina
realmente te preocupas por las personas
porque entonces puedes mirar más allá de
lo que son y verlas como lo que
realmente pueden ser eso es especies y
cuarta ronda la eliminación debo
eliminar aún a alexa debe eliminar a una
persona de la cinta rápida
voy a tener que eliminar a sham la vibra
que estoy recibiendo no es tan fuerte
como las otras dos que he recibido
[Música]
la ronda final son así que como no hay
apuntador a aquí quisiera saber un poco
de ti que te gusta me gusta bailar
espera espera del detente y bailar
estamos hablando de salsa o breakdance
porque me gustan ambos más de hip hop
que de cualquier atracos ok eso es
genial que más te gusta me gusta cantar
estuve cantando durante todo el camino
está encanto
es genial pero qué hay de la fotografía
tengo un poco de curiosidad por eso te
gustan los paisajes los relatos mi
enfoque principal podría decirse que es
el retrato también me gusta fotografiar
animales como la vida salvaje no seguro
te gustaría fotografiar que es lo más
difícil por lo que has pasado como lo
superas te y como eso te llevó a ser
quién eres o hoy en día una de las cosas
más duras por la que tuve que pasar fue
probablemente entré a la escuela
intermedia y principios de secundaria
porque me di con mucha depresión y con
problemas de confianza en mí misma
lo supere porque empecé a quererme a mí
misma soy muy extrovertida y ayudo a las
personas así que ayudar a su animador me
ayuda así eso es increíble bueno
definitivamente diría que tienes que
aceptar quién eres porque eres única y
lo que puedes aportar al mundo es
diferente a cualquier otra persona eso
te hace lo que eres hoy en día sabes si
la eliminación alexa debe elegir a una
persona para pedirle que tengan una
segunda cita
agregó que tome una decisión muy bien
así que voy a elegir a joseph esta
última pregunta que me hizo me demuestra
que puede ser realmente profundo cuando
lo amerita y ese es el tipo de cosas que
estoy buscando quiero alguien con quien
pueda divertirme mucho pero con quien
pueda ser muy seria cuando llegue el
momento esto lo pone por encima del
estándar es lo que estuve buscando
gracias
[Música]
cómo te sientes ahora mismo
definitivamente estoy más acostumbrado a
hablar con las personas cara a cara y
ser más real es raro ya sabes les
gustaría ver si de eso se trata sí
eres linda un placer conocerte un placer
conocerte cómo estás y en ti estoy bien
estoy bien no me imaginaba que fuera así
pero estoy muy contenta eres muy lindo
gracias gracias y espero que esto vaya a
alguna parte supongo bueno tengo novia
aunque bien es realmente buena tú eres
increíble pero esto acaba de pasar
caramba
[Risas]
si no puede para qué viniste soy el
único que tiene novia aquí
en serio si no puede ser le conté a mi
novia todo sobre esto y ella dijo que
sonaba como un experto pero no sabía
cinco minutos después
así
y pensé que era una especie de broma que
estaba muy sorprendida y entonces note
que todos estaban muy sorprendidos no
fue una broma fue muy raro porque me
metí en esto pensando que iba a terminar
con alguien que estuviera soltero pero
quiero decir que no estoy herida ni nada
solo estoy un poco confundida en cuanto
a por qué él estaba aquí estoy
sorprendida sin importar lo que pasó
estoy feliz de que tengo una novia
porque él es realmente una persona
genial y tenía todo lo que yo estaba
buscando así que debe tener todo lo que
ella estaba buscando también espero que
sean muy felices
ah
jubilee